e
e e
probably figured he's not coming if
probably figured he's not coming
back all right but they're still they're
still in the same order right okay all
right this is the uh work session for
uh on on House Bill 12
1229 relative to the purchase and sale
of any interest in Real Property AB
budding public Waters and I think I
should recognize uh representative oh
wait yeah before I jump in I apologize I
just need
retraining uh we salute the pledge of
the flag it's been a long time since
I've been
here please join with me in a pledge to
our flag I pledge to the flag United
States of America and to the rep for it
stands
nais yeah interesting is that the new
pool is that the new swimming pool yeah
Dees hasn't had a chance to look at
it there's a big there's a large hole
full of water
outside so all right let's get represent
rung if you'd like to speak uh on this
on this issue thank you very much Mr
chair um before the public hearing when
this came before us um I had met with u
Mr Quinn from the New Hampshire realtors
association
and I you know he showed me the um
paperwork that's used in a sale of
property and where I wanted to have some
notice to the buyer of their
responsibility and the under the
shoreline water quality protection act
that they would be alerted there really
wasn't um an appropriate space on that
form to do that and Our intention was to
work together to find another solution
to it but it's not going to happen
through this bill um so um I'd like to
make a motion not to recommend this um
and I would I'm going to just continue
to work with Mr Quinn and see if we can
find a non-legislative
um solution to um make sure that um
there's com a greater compliance with
the shoreline water quality protection
act okay all right though this is a work
session so we I'm sorry sorry I'm just
explaining to every okay that we uh
we're not taking any motions we're
taking uh uh we're discussing the uh
issue and also we're going to be taking
uh uh a input from members of the public
okay okay
so so that's just my yeah so I think you
know initially I wanted if you look at
the purchase and sales agreement that's
signed between the seller and the buyer
there are sections where the seller has
to or the the buyer is getting
notification about something it could be
wellwater you know potential
contaminants and well water for instance
um radon um stuff like that but that
notice that would impact someone's
health or their ability to use the
property the notice I I want to give to
buyers doesn't fall into that category
um it's really just saying you're now
purchasing property within a shoreline
protection Zone and you have there's
compli there's compliance that you have
to ensure occurs because of the
shoreline water quality protection act
um but that form that purchase and sales
form isn't going to be um the
appropriate vehicle to make that
communication so um I think this bill
just needs to have a dignified dep and
um I'd like to work with the Realtors on
maybe a a pamphlet or some other
communication relating to that property
that they can be given that's kind of
outlines what their responsibilities are
you know for in I'll give you an example
um I don't live my my home in Mar Mac
doesn't abut any public Waters so my
husband and I can cut down trees um we
it really isn't a big concern but if you
do that on property that's within 50 ft
of the shoreline you are very limited in
the trees that you can cut there has to
be very specific measurements done of
the number of trees there circumference
you can't exceed a certain total
circumference so that's something that
people may not even be aware that they
have to comply with that because if
they're moving from a property that
doesn't that isn't AB buding public
Waters that has never been a concern to
them until they're within the shoreline
and I'm sorry I I only had one cup of
coffee today
so but uh anyway so that's why I mean
the bill definitely had good intentions
I think particularly with the summer
we've had with cyanobacteria blooms
there now has been a lot of attention on
the shoreline protection act and what
has to happen to comply with it and I
think I think some of the um
environmental organizations like Lake W
nasaki Association um oapi Alliance um
New Hampshire Lakes has certainly ramped
up a lot of education on this um and I
think that should continue and I just
think it's still kind of we're we're
going in the right direction I'm not
quite sure it's at a point where we need
legislation on
it so so you have not uh or do not
intend to
put forth legislation correct this term
yeah any questions uh or any comments by
other members of the
committee representative harm thank you
Mr chair I I when it comes time for
executing I would support that motion
for maybe a slightly different reason
but for the same result that I think it
needs a little more study okay thank you
is there uh any
uh anyone from
audience who wishes to speak to this
issue before we before I take
a a and it'll be a show of hands because
we're not taking the vote with will not
take the actual vote on
anything uh at this at the this this at
this part of the hearing at this hearing
but we will have be executing at all of
these at
11:30 representative wolf
I can agree with representative rung
that this bill as presented isn't ready
for prime time but I
do now that I'm leaving leave it up to
you people that I think there should be
some sort of notification we see this
around our Lakes all the time where
people come up
they build Beaches they put uh cut trees
and oh I didn't know it was any
different than where I live and I think
there should be some sort of
notification when somebody purchases
property it's not ready in this bill but
please don't let it
die okay anyone else in the committee I
do have an additional question myself
anyone else uh additional oh
sorry thank you Mr chair I put my hand
up at the last minute um I just wanted
to say Yes um we I know that there's a
lot of um progress made with Watershed
plans in the lakes and there's it's a
really complicated issue so I really
appreciate um pursuing a non-legislative
solution and working with people because
it seems like you would be able to do a
lot more that way thank
you I have a additional question is uh
have you do you have thoughts on any on
the mechanism of the creation of this
probably a form uh notification form
would you
envision uh it being put forth by
created uh under the opes of Dees there
may be be a form on
de's uh website that the uh the Realtors
can go to a common form that and will it
be that they just be able to print it
off and or
get get it from Dees in some way other
words Dees would
beate would create the form and
not uh the the
Realtors yeah I think the initial intent
was to have it the the content come from
Dees but um and but Dees has a lot of
information about the responsibilities
of Shoreland owners um and actually
after this summer I've heard that you
know instead of just focusing on people
who are buying property new owners that
there needs to be education of all
owners um that you know if we just do
this education buyer by buyer we may be
only hitting a very small percentage of
people within that Shoreline protection
Zone um but I I know that in wolfb they
had um some Community meetings where I'm
not I think it might have been Lake
winaki Association maybe New Hampshire
Lakes they hosted Community meetings um
with the town and I think as long as we
continue that discussion and work with
like New Hampshire Lakes for example on
doing broader communication so that
anyone living within the shoreline
protection Zone whether they're just
buying property or not has a greater
understanding of what their
responsibilities are so we this just FOC
Fus is on new buyers I'm not sure that's
going to be sufficient to get us where
we have to go on cyano bacteria Bloom
mitigation that we need to do something
broader to reach all residents and it
may not be something that is as
efficiently accomplished by the state as
much as it might be by local
communities um there was a bill um it
actually failed in the house I think by
one boat that representative wolf
brought that I think would be I I'd like
to see that bill come back where we add
Watershed zones to um a definition of a
a special district for instance in my
town babusek lake has been plagued by
cyanobacteria blooms for years and years
and they've done so much um but if they
could form a special district with
Amherst that special district would have
a lot of power on education more than uh
you know one town doing it for their
half another town doing it for their
half or the state trying to do something
for a small like like
that my concern is
that responsibilities
and for doing stuff and responsibility
for creating
something uh needs to be determined is
it will Dees have to make the
have to publish this thing or where does
people get stuff when uh you know when
you when you don't have
responsibility established in the in the
in in the uh in the
statute you if if if nobody's
responsible then if everybody's
responsible then nobody's responsible so
that's just make that a concern when you
uh as you go forward that someone has to
come out with somebody has to be
responsible for creating the
system well another Point too Mr chair
is that a lot of towns have adopted the
shoreline water quality protection act
as local ordinance and I think that's a
good tactic also because you're bringing
enforcement and education really down to
that local level so when you talk about
responsibility in some cases I would put
more um
reliability or trust on local
communities to have it to protect their
own
ordinances um than having a state having
to focus in all of these communities for
education I I think if we can um
encourage more towns to adopt the
shoreline water quality protection act
as an
ordinance that would streamline
education a lot more than expecting
something to happen at the state level
anyone else on the uh on this
issue one from the
audience uh I'll just take a show of
hands who I guess the recommendation
would will probably be uh not to not
recommend for future
legislation U how many let me he a s of
hands of those who would
uh y yes it would be uh
see a
unanimous okay we want to move on now
to something that isn't going to be
necessarily unanimous House Bill
1483 allowing subdivision regulations
concerning water
supply any comments on uh
folks there any
uh well this uh this is
a look let me look at
the this is a lot this is a lot more
complicated
than going back
there's originally
well this bill as it as it's written is
allows adoption of subdivision
regulations to require water supply
studies determination of adequate water
supply for
reasonably uh anticipated future water
uses uh and minimum lawn lot size
minimum unlock private well testing
requirements and clarifies the
applicant's duty to pay
Associated costs so this is this is
actually an enabling
legislation to have the local
have uh this have the authority to
require uh water
studies on uh on projects I I correct me
if anybody well it says require so can
we have some clarification the first all
right word is required okay well that's
that's first but just just as clear as
questions of just I'm just answering
representative Horgan's but
right Mr chair as a member of the
planning board we did require water
studies traffic
studies all kinds of
studies and it I'm just um so it says a
letter P says require a water supply
study in I guess in in accordance but
then it says um
May uh down at letter you know number
seven planning board May so maybe some
clarification
okay is that a response to the
clarification thank you Mr chair so if
you read the the statute 674
362 it says the subdivision regulation
which the planning board adopts May so
all of those fall under the May category
they may they may require
it up y so are you saying now does
anybody know for a fact that they cannot
do this right now because it is my
understanding that studies that are
needed we would need to interpret I
think we need to interpret the other uh
what is it
um 12 13 uh 14 regulations uh 14 uh
clauses
that have that allow options and see if
any of them incorporate it because
there's 14 cases a one through or sorry
a through n that say they may do this
and they may do that and these are
adding this bill adds three
morea har thank you Mr chair I'm still
of the opinion I was when I wrote the
majority opinion that I think as
representative Horgan says it can be
done now uh there are towns that are
already got water testing in there I
know they've done water testing in
plasta where I come from um and then I
go back to um the uh commissioner
Scott's comment that they had a whole
study committee on this and they
couldn't come up with a decision so if
it ain't broke don't fix it so I'm
thinking it can be there towns are doing
it you don't need to enable them to do
it so I would not think legislation is
necessary thank
you any other comments on
this
representative thank you Mr
chair so my understanding is that the
bill has been refiled I'm not sure if
it's going to be the same text if the um
sponsor was able to um develop the bill
based on what came out of the hearing
but um in terms of studying it we are
still in the same place I think where we
were to begin with we heard that um
developers can come in and they can take
adequate water supply for granted so
that's a quote from what the sponsor
testified um in reality local planners
should be enabled to make sure that
there's water but I do believe we have
to enable them at the state level
again really though this bill will be
refiled and there will be time and
opportunity to
see the Genesis of what happened that
brought the bill forward because there's
an incident and get that testimony thank
you Derby for a second thank you uh Mr
chair just a statement that um I don't
believe um that it is covered the only
coverage of um water usage talks about
health and safety
and the concern that um the
um author of the bill mentioned was that
when you draw from an aquifer you're not
um it's not localized it had aquafer
extends Beyond maybe the um the location
of the
subdivision um and it can draw from uh
Farms it can draw from um it can draw
from other residences um and there uh
there's an impact that
there's a study is a is an impact study
that's required to understand what the
um what the surrounding uh you what what
the harm could be to other areas I don't
see that um that harm covered anywhere
in uh in this to um it really talks
about things like um fire suppression um
and uh playgrounds and things like that
so I think this is I'm the reason that
this went to inim study I vot I um cast
the the lone vote on um the opposing s
on the Democratic side for this um uh
but I um I think that something needs to
be done I think that when the um the
study that um representative harb
referenced came out there was a um there
was a statement um that that a need is
required um yes it's um the need is
unclear but a need is required and the
petitioner um the sponsor stated that
they're that they're seeing problems uh
in their own community so this is not
this doesn't Force the hand of anyone
this enables um and it's not clear to me
that this enables in a bad way at all um
I'd say that um what is what would be a
bad uh what would be a negative impact
is if we um you know reduce the ability
to farm on adjacent lands by drawing
down Aqua first or if we um impacted the
property values of adjacent uh
properties because we didn't adequately
evaluate the um the impacts of adding
you know 50 50 houses in a subdivision
so um I I definitely believe personally
believe that this uh bill is required
thanks
representative thank you Mr chair um so
I have a question about what is the
constraints around scope of project so
I'm I'm I'm reading this is it requires
a water supply study on every project
that comes into a community or is this
just constrained to larger projects so
being a state rep from Salem we just had
a um huge uh planning board meeting last
night where they're looking at putting
in a casino where it's was the old Lord
and Taylor so that's a very large
project but then you know you may have
another the same night you could have
the same person coming in saying I'd
like to build a new house and I'd like
to do this following thing which is a
much different constraint but do both
have to do water
studies based on this bill so that's the
confusion I
have
representative question I have in my
mind or what I'm looking at is we're not
here to discuss the technical little
issues of any proposed bill it's just
should we recommend future legislation
or not so I mean all of us could come up
with amendments to the bill that may
have been presented uh but if my
representative to my right is correct
and it's already been refiled I'm still
going to stick to the position I don't
think it's necessary because it's
already been refiled so ours is just a
recommendation so the sponsors already
refiled it then it's going to come back
to the committee and then we get a
chance to review it and edit it and
amend it Etc so thank you one thing oh
go oh yeah I just uh it is has been
refiled it's LSR 2025
0049 and it was refiled by
representative
McGee but we wouldn't know we wouldn't
have access to what the uh no but it has
the same title as this bill
right now
thank you Mr chair um I just want to
respond to um representative harb and
that's to say that a couple of things
have already come up on this bill that I
can see are concerns and I'm really glad
the representative um from Salem is here
and able to recommend raining in the
scope and how many houses is at one
house these are important things and
this is time we have to be more relaxed
when we weren't when we ordered you know
we voted to have this interim study at a
time when we were moving along pretty
quickly yep all right let me let me step
back first of all let's just look at uh
what the uh the blurbs were and actually
it was a it was an 11 to9 it was an 11
to9 vote out of this committee so to to
go to uh uh it refer to interm study the
other
that 11 was uh was uh interim study and
nine was for
uh
or uh to uh to pass it to pass the Bill
uh that being said this bill has a
Genesis from the bill from the
previous Set uh part of this session
310 and and that bill rather than
talking
about uh just allowing subdivis
regulations concerning water supply
talked about allowing again the same
thing it was
about requiring developers to secure
hydrology
analyses certified that their adequate
water capacity and Pro pability when
building new
subdivisions it so that bill
was we that bill was was uh did not come
out of the was defeated by the committee
uh 310 well no and and that was on a 16
to4
vote uh that and basically we were told
that uh hydrology studies were
very
uh uh they were they were expensive to
start with very very expensive they were
talked about their testimonies to say
$100,000 to
do
and the uh uh they could change at any
time somebody uh in the Watershed or
somebody just down the block decides
that they're going to change uh going to
do something about their well to get a
get more flow which is many times it's
putting a a charge down and uh and
just and basically put it like an
explosive in the in the well not a big
explosive but enough to crack some more
uh channels that can cause an issue
there basically it can change the
uh the water is to you can't you have to
drill a hell of a lot of holes to get on
real hydrology stud but that's that's
basically
what what was left at also it was a big
issue
around uh Workforce housing discussion
like that and issues
around uh checkerboarding if you do if
want someone wishes to uh
to bypass the regulation they
simply sell sell Parcels of land uh in
the they'll re subdivide so that you you
sell off the parcels so that when you go
into to
develop uh you don't you all you own is
one or two parcels and other other could
other uh ownership rests for the rather
land rests without other uh rest with
other
entities uh other
than so and then
finally in this bill as it exists now
doesn't seem to
mention hydrological
testing but it it it doesn't really say
what
the what the locals uh the the local
uh government will ask for in there in
their regulations will they ask for
hydrological testing in
their uh in their regulations and will
this enable them to do
that that's always that's that is that
is also a question I understand that uh
there was we found that that was sent to
us by uh
uh Mr Kernan uh a model the model
ordinance that was developed by the uh
uh
the commission that ex that looked at
this I guess back in 2008 and on the
model
ordinance uh it it's it there there are
some conflicting issues as to what what
the uh what this bill would be actually
be requ quiring uh the model ordinance
talks about doing a hydrological testing
or doesn't even actually mentioned the
hydrological testing but uh uh on but on
larger the subdivisions not on for on uh
on and this one doesn't even mention
what the subdivision will be the the
model ordinance was sent to everyone
after during uh after
by uh Mr
kman uh prior uh to our actually to our
executing that
bill
so that's I think so that's kind of this
bill has a
history and one of my one of my large my
biggest concerns is that when we we
have you we here who deal with Dees
we know we know what where the uh Dees
we understand what their rules
are and we see how they apply those
rules and when you when you when you
allow this to go back into the
towns you now you we don't look at how
they apply those rules and we've seen
and several times
where they they will will go they will
read the letter of the law and not
understand how the rules are
actually implemented because you know
and they they've gotten into some
problems I think one of those had to do
with h $5,000 fines when someone takes a
tree down next to a next to a
Waterway so uh whereas that $5,000 fine
in de's mind was used to force people to
to to to to do what they're supposed to
be doing to uh relative to the
uh basically large
developers so at any rate this is
there's a ISS there are issues with this
and that that's my biggest
concern thank you for um outlining that
and bringing back some of the history um
Mr chair um the bill does have a history
his and looking at that vote now going
back to the first bill which was House
Bill 310 that vote came out of it um you
know there were many of us who wanted to
work on that bill but the sponsor wasn't
available at the time and Brendan Kieran
came in and he testified that he was
working with her on this
so she came back with a better bill and
we sent it to interim study but that
better Bill we didn't really get a
chance to work on that with the sponsor
and Dees at the same time the first time
around so I do hope I'm glad to see that
this got refiled
and I think that we're going to stick to
our votes most likely on um
recommending any uh other comments I
members of the
committee any comments by uh people in
the
audience by the way what obviously you
must be here for the last
one okay sorry about that if I had known
that I'd have switched them
around
representative thank you Mr chair I did
make my position known I will say that
um I am worried of course about
Workforce housing I think it's the top
issue in the state um and we need to be
cautious to uh we need to be able to
encourage um uh developers to to build
we need houses um and definitely uh cost
prohibitive um uh forget the word you
use but aquafer studies you know um
would thank you hydrological studies
would be you know disruptive to that
regard and the term that's used in this
did um doesn't seem seem to be well
defined by Dees in terms of um a water
supply study so I do hope that when it
gets refiled um that that can be that
Clarity can be added so I I just wanted
to make that statement thank
you
well anyone
else if if not though I'll take a show
of hands
and who will vote who might wish to vote
for uh to not recommend for future for
future study but not
recommending and who would for recommend
to recommend for future
study okay so it's it's so we are we are
divided obviously so uh we at the end
when we have our executive session
we we'll take a vote on it and uh but as
I think I've been
discussing with the ranking member that
uh me my intent to put in the in any
write up when there's
disagreement it is I mean this is it it
is really uh we wish we should could try
to put give as much information
it's a a bunch guidance to the to
whoever is to to the Future basically
this is a note to ourselves or put it
this way it's a note to
yourselves uh because I will not be here
but it's it's some of others but it
uh but the the pros and cons should be
in should be in what we write what we
what we write just to yeah the majority
said this ority but the minority said
that and that's that's reasonable in
this in instance I may get held for it
but what they going to do kick me off
the
committee
so can't do that I kicked myself off
so so that that's where we'll go on this
one now for the last
one uh Senate Bill
three by the way have we finished on
that okay Senate Bill
345 what is the
uh any any call any uh thoughts on
that okay we go go down the line
representative Darby representative FR
thanks um thank you Mr chair so I'm
serving on the um uh the study committee
for fishing game funding one of the
things that's um that came up from the
Department is how hard it is for fishing
game which is a self-funded uh agency to
balance their books when the legislature
plays games behind their backs with um
with fees and so um we we ask a lot of
of our um our agencies to um you know to
be fair to uh our residents um and also
to you know provide an attract Ive uh
environment to our visitors because
tourism is a um major um economic boom
and I don't U believe that the
legislature should be um directing the
fee structure to these uh self-funded
agencies
thanks representative R I agree with my
colleague from NASA
about you know how we're we kind of
nickel and dime through legislation what
our fees are going to be and I'd Like Us
in that regard if we could operate more
like a business and have the state parks
division really look holistically at
their budget how much money they need to
operate how much money they would want
to have to operate and knowing that we
want to give Granite Staters an
advantage we want to make it easier for
them to enjoy their own state but have
that be part of an overall um strategy
or or a business plan for setting the
fees because you know we set fees here
we just had a fee for retired military
and we we kind of have this Patchwork
that comes out of the legislature
instead of really looking at it um from
a really strategic development business
business planning point of view because
we do want the fees to be
self-sufficient for the state park they
can't rely on really the general fund um
when we're cutting down the revenue for
the general fund we you know we're
cutting taxes we're getting rid of
dividends and interest um so this money
isn't growing on trees to support our
state parks and they're the ones that
know best of what they're going to need
to operate to the standard that they
that they need to operate and then if
they knew that the legislative intent is
to have an advantage for granted sters
they can that can then be part of an
overall free fee structure strategy um I
also sometimes have concerns when you
see numbers thrown out like 50% because
why not 40% why not 60% it's you know
it's arbitrary where if somebody really
sits down and and looks at the numbers
look at projections resources things
like that all the statistics that they
should be looking at anyway they could
come to a number that is more logical um
maybe it's higher maybe it's lower but I
I'd rather have them develop their fees
um justify them and then come to us to
recommend them um rather than having us
without the knowledge or data they have
trying to make these decisions in a
patchwork type of frame thank
you yeah she raise her hand first
then thank thank you Mr chair I'm um
go ahead uh I'm one of the sponsors on
the bill and um I think in gen you know
after giving it a lot of
thought I I do want to cut New Hampshire
residents break but I also agree with
some of the other sentiments that I
don't want to complicate things anymore
I think we're already we are very much
piece you
know the danger is cut you know chopping
things up too much I think and making it
more complicated I don't want to make it
more complicated for sure so um I
think I would be okay with with sort of
putting this on hold for now and coming
at it from maybe a different approach if
somebody wants to work with me on it as
far as instead of having it something uh
giving New Hampshire residents a break
as far as fees because they're already
pretty low I think um doing something
else that is a sort of like maybe giving
them a a bigger window of opportunity
when it comes to signing up for
campsites something that does not
involve another fee structure change so
I'd be love to hear if uh New Hampshire
parks people have some thoughts on
thanks why don't I just keep going right
around like that of Representative ghoul
then representative Bale representative
Ryan then
representative okay thank you uh Mr
chairman uh
referring to what the former
representative mentioned about a
business structure uh I don't know if
this really fits in uh this seems to be
mainly about RS to get into a park for
example uh a group was trying to use the
state park at Hampton Beach and uh the
rates did go up fin uh substantially for
parking there for the
organization and uh this created a
problem for them and uh so they are
working
to raise rates without affecting the
simple you know fee structure of getting
into a park so EV it seems to me they
are looking at it to get money somehow
and uh but I also would since there are
a couple people here I would urge them
to get their permits going faster than
they have
been representative Vale and
representative Ryan and representative w
well you're
okay thank you Mr
chair so I just prepared some notes so
I'm just basically going to read them
there is a process for changing fees
that the um legislature has oversight on
and those go before the fiscal committee
and you know that we heard that the
director of New Hampshire state parks
the division has been addressing fee
changes at the park throughout Parks
throughout the state in fact one of the
um Parks is closed right now for to have
Capital Improvements and upgrades and
that's um I believe Greenfield State
Park um and this is really a
vastly complicated issue um I think you
know as as far as the state parks
advisory Council goes which I serve on I
mean we do hear about the um the push
for hiring the issues with temporary
workers that where they can't come
necessarily and then you balance that
with some of our
awardwinning um features we have a visit
New Hampshire campaign live free um and
they left the Die part off which I think
is fantastic but there's a lot of moving
parts and this is an Enterprise we are
trying to attract people to our state
and it's a really big picture so I think
for us to go in there and Tinker a
little bit at a time when there's a lot
of moving pirates with Federal money and
you know kind of sit back and see where
we are and see what kind of leg
legislative help is needed for state
parks and I think we can do
that representative Ryan and
representative thank you Mr chair um as
I've I think I've been on record before
saying I don't think it's really our
business or our job I think that if
we're going to require the state parks
to um fund themselves then they need to
be able to do that without legislative
[Music]
interference representative
representative
wolf yes I think that um the um parks
department should be able to go to the
fiscal committee adjust their fees based
upon a thorough examination of what it's
costing them to run it I think just
arbitrarily saying it's 50% of what we
charge out of sters or something like
that it's no no basis for reality in
that and so I would put this bill aside
leave the system we have but direct the
parks department to do a more thorough
analysis of the actual operating
costs anyone
else I know representative Donell you
did write the blur I was as if you wanna
if if you want to say anything I'm not
I'm not asking you to
say all
right okay so do you want to you want to
speak on it Okay
no Okay I uh I have I should put my I
got to put my three not my two cents my
three cents in
uh couple things first of all yeah yes
we uh
the the operate you oper as a state you
are
operationally the parks system is
operationally self-funded you're not
self-funded for uh Capital equip Capital
Improvements right that does come from
the general fund and also you there's
also monies that you get outside of this
outside that get get into the into the
system uh yes you are an Enterprise or
supposedly an
Enterprise uh operation
however we and the uh in the uh in the
legislature seem
to uh use the park system and the as a
uh as a political tool
people are people my age come in oh I'm
I'm retired I need I I should get a
break I'm a citizen uh people come in
uh part of the specific groups they
should get a break there all of these
things and and we
by legisl we as legislators will pass
laws that force that to occur that that
is n made by a so that those decisions
aren't made by them that decisions is
are made by
us if I had my way anytime we we do
something like that we ought to we ought
to reimburse the try the fund for
uh uh the uh operational
fund by from the general fund but that's
I'm I cannot affect that and I will not
be around to affect that the but to get
back to this bill
specifically this bill recognizes that
other
states charge more for a specific for a
specific
fee to people from our state in other
words out of sters than they do to their
local to their PE to their people we on
the other hand don't do
that so that if if I were a citizen and
I am a citizen I would sit back and say
hey wait a minute my government has
decided
that those people get a break
here because they pay the same as me but
I don't get the same break over there so
I'm being treated as second class or at
least I'm not be my state isn't backing
me up so we as legislators will be
will'll constantly hear that hey I
wanted we I'm I'm a citizen I should
have I pay for this park yeah you do
prefer parts of it yeah I pay for this
park so why shouldn't I
have some a little bit of the fat and
get a little bit more pay a little bit
less get a discount for because I I
already paid at the at the at the tax
man or I already paid for this fee by
being a citizen
so realize that that pressure is always
going to be
there
and we should be doing something to be
able to or at some point and and I think
with with the with the we are ought to
be working with
the park management to to have them s
kind of think ahead that take the
pressure off of the
legislature that maybe
give show that you're playing that
you're thinking about the
residence of New
Hampshire and not just and at least that
we that we are better than Massachusetts
and how they treat their
residents because their residents get a
break there so at any rate be aware of
that and uh because this is this issue
is not going
away now if you don't better to bite it
and better to to chew on it now and make
it make it come out with a way that
you're giving something to the
residents other than having it come
through the
legislature they able to raise the
outstate reg oh they can do whatever
they
want but they decided they don't want to
so you know soon if if the wrong if you
if you come with an legisl you come if a
legislature is elected that you get a
majority say hey come on or if you get a
governor who go starts saying hey uh
what's you know uh you better you better
do this better to get out in front of it
and so that's all I'm saying fix
this can we hear from oh I know if you
want you could respond I mean leave me
or say I mean we're not we're not saying
yeah you're here to talk if you want us
to respond yeah uh if I I'm not going to
say yes but if one want to ask folks
yeah yeah all
right all right first representative uh
Bale I just wanted to say that state
parks has worked with us on this bill
and we've spent a lot of time talking
about fees and I really appreciate that
you came today because we you know we I
understand the legislature wants more
information so perhaps knowing
the balance between visiting New
Hampshire and trying to charge more
money well good morning everybody uh my
name is uh Sean Hamilton I am the deputy
supervisor of park
operations um I've worked for state
parks for almost 15 years in varing
capacities starting at as a park crew
member at pway State Park when I was in
college so I've seen it at all um and um
you know one of the things that I would
say is I think there's two separate
issues as as I see it and I do think yes
fees is part of the conversation but
really the complaint that I hear most
often is in regard to some sort of
preferential um for New Hampshire
residents which I believe one of the
representatives brought up in uh in
terms of maybe potentially a uh window
an earlier window for New Hampshire
residents versus out of residents um I
don't hear too many complaints about the
fees themselves to be quite honest with
you it is more about being able to get
into a park uh when they when a
constituent wants to get into a park um
so for instance you know it's a Saturday
in July a visitor pulls up at 11:00 a.m.
it's a very busy day the park is full
because of reservations are being at
capacity uh and they're not able to get
in and that upsets them and and I I
understand that um but what I would say
is that uh there are some systems in
place already such as our reservation
system which would allow for these
visitors to be able to guarantee their
access into the park and prevent that
situation from
happening um in regards to the fees
there has been a uh systematic approach
at looking at the fee package over the
last two years uh and and it had
involved the state park advisory Council
uh and as well as uh the leadership team
uh field staff it was compris comprised
of many members of the division and uh
we have taken it piece by piece looking
at the fee package starting with the
parking fees for the Sea Coast going to
uh camping fees uh and then obviously
dayuse uh fees are are the piece that we
still have to
address without going too far into the
nuances and and I I'm not disagreeing
that there has to be some sort of um
compromise here in figuring something
out to prove residency versus
non-residency upon entrance of the park
is a little bit more complicated than
than you would think most of our Parks
currently are per person rate which
would mean that we would have to prove
The Residency of each individual uh in a
vehicle as they enter the park um not to
say that that's not possible but it's
not possible through our online systems
at the moment because that would require
us to integrate with the DMV database
which I uh don't think would be allowed
at this current time um so that would
significantly slow down the entrance of
the park um you would have to you would
have major traffic backups and
congestion and things like that so um
just want to point that part out I mean
one of our M the first impression that
someone has of in Hampshire state park
is when they get to the to the toll
booth of the entrance gate and um we
want that to be seamless and smooth and
so figuring out how to accomplish a
proof of residency while not impacting
that is probably part of the challenge
that we have to uh
address I could go on but I won't unless
you want me
to any any
questions know I note I did note that
the uh
in the
bill uh there was uh there's a section
that says residency may be indicated by
state issued
identification utility or tax bills
vehicle registrations student
identification or vehicle license plates
so so that was was addressed in actually
in Bill if you base it on the license
plate however you could potentially be
giving a resident discount to
out ofate people so if I came with five
people in my vehicle four of them were
from out of state and I based it solely
on the license plate they could also
receive that benefit so and and a good
and a good so a good followup uh to that
would in the in any future legislation
was simply putting in that uh uh an
unsworn falsification this you
know having someone in your vehicle who
is not uh uh uh a
resident should be declared if not it's
an un un unsworn falsification with a
fine of
$5,000 beyond
that um just a a followup on that um
like we have a benefit as state reps we
can go to the park for free um but so
for instance when I drive in yeah state
parks
yeah is that I mean I've gotten into
quite a few correct this summer
so yeah it is yeah
price I think it depends on what it I
I've been to uh the beach every time I
went to Northampton uh Hampton Beach
State
Park should
be um anyway so we get benefit we come
in they don't ask me if my mother is
from New Hampshire or whoever my guest
is that I'm taking with me so I assume
it's a similar sort of thing is that
right where you you don't ask those sort
of questions of everybody in the car
right thanks um well at Hampton Beach
it's a parking fee so we only go off the
the driver of the vehicle at our parking
fee Parks we have a small number of
parks that are a parking fee that would
be Hampton Beach South Wallace Sands
Livermore Falls um and obviously our
Meed parking is different the the rest
of the parks however are a per person
fee so in that particular instance if
you went to another Park that was a per
person Park they they would ask um that
information anyone
else um I just not to be nitpicky but it
could happen the other way around too
where somebody has new somebody has
Massachusetts plate but they picked up
their grandmother on the way and in fact
this is Grandma's favorite Lake and she
lives in New
Hampshire just closing remarks I
appreciate the discussion on this
today yeah I mean I don't think we're
changing they going to change the actual
boat than thank you Mr chair I want to
take advantage of you being here and uh
how how is this state park doing like
what percentage is covered by fees of
your overall
budget it's a very good question
um you know I I I would want to have
more detailed information in front of me
to be honest with you uh at the time but
but I I we have done well in in revenue
and I would attribute that to multiple
different things one uh the re
reservation system uh that we have
implemented Ed uh the Davis reservation
system which I think partly brought this
issue to light to be quite honest with
you uh in the fall of 2019 so prior to
co many think that we launched the
reservation system during Co we did not
we launched it in the fall of 2019 at
madok State Park uh and that was a
result of um large crowds the park was
constantly being full so so to manage
the resource not only to manage the
carrying capacity of the park but also
to manage the social
uh carrying capacity of the park as well
because we need to manage responsibly
the resource but also at the same time
we need to preserve the visitor
experience which all of our visitors
have come to expect when they come to a
New Hampshire state park so we we
launched that system it largely
successful there in accomplishing those
two goals but also what we found was
people were a lot more compliant in
terms of paying their fees U being
honest coming up to the gate um and and
it was a much more pleasant experience
for everyone overall so during Co to gos
as well as the adhering to the co
guidelines uh and then from there we
kept it in place and what it has allowed
us to do is to capture Revenue uh that
we otherwise uh would have had more
difficulty uh collecting for various
reasons you know whether the park
Staffing is not at the level that it
that it maybe needs to be given our
seasonal Workforce although we have done
I believe a good job and and building up
that Workforce um and it has allowed us
to put uh capture points in terms of
Revenue so for instance um we have
created uh online donation items for
unstaffed parks where we put signage up
with QR codes that someone can come up
to the their sign with their phone click
it and give us uh some fees for their
use of the park there's not actually a
staff member there collecting that fee
um so so these different and also we've
launched an online donation page that's
just sort of a standalone page we've put
in some other uh nuances you know for
instance um if someone were to cancel
their camping reservation it sends them
a cancellation email and then it asks
them would you want to give a percentage
of your can your refund back to New
Hampshire state parks as a donation do
you want to give the whole thing back um
so implementing these strategies has
helped us although at the same time our
uh expenses have in increased
significantly uh over the last uh 10
years uh we are working on an analysis
right now that shows that our uh
operating expenses and in the park
operations Bureau which is where I am
have about doubled um over the last 10
years so that that's significant and
also to to build up that robust
Workforce that we're trying to
build we we had to make uh changes to to
uh to pay obviously some of that was
part of the 10% that was implemented but
also changes in the management structure
as well to implement some different uh
classifications to to give us a a higher
level of of management and uh Staffing
so hope that answers your question I
certainly could follow up with some more
detailed information after this if you
like
Darby thank thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming in you mentioned that the
what you've heard the most um most
request for is some kind of prefer
ential um reservation um do you know if
other states are doing something similar
and how they um you know how they're
accomplishing that in terms of
residency um some other states do uh
offer some Advanced window um how
successful it is I would leave that up
to them to to say uh what I would say
though is it would be uh remarkably
difficult for us given the online you
know over 95% of our reservations are
made online without being able to
integrate into any sort of database that
would verify residency online that would
allow for someone to abuse the system so
at the end of the day it would come down
to a proof of residency
onsite um so yes we could implement it
but it it has the potential to be abused
and unfortunately that would not be
caught until the reservation holder was
on site arriving at at the park whether
that be for dayuse or
camping I'm also very conscious of the
you know our staff is comprised mostly
of high school college aged students as
well as
retirees
um conflict with uh visitors over
disagreements about how we are enforcing
said rules and policies is is highly
probable um and given that we are trying
to retain in whatever way we can the
workforce so that we can provide the uh
recreational experience that that our
visitors expect uh I'm very cautious
about about that and how we approach it
not saying uh but that all being said we
are working uh with our reservation
system vendor to see what type of
strategies we could Implement um to to
to make the ver to make a verif
verification process possible
your followup thank you Mr chair um I'll
just point out of course that another um
another agency that brings a lot of
residents from out of state um is
hunting and fishing and of course
there's out of state um differences
between resident and non-resident
hunting and fishing licenses and every
state implements that so there is I
think there might be a way
thanks representative Harvey Poli lot
really quickly um just thank you for
your comments and if you aren't in fate
or if you'd rather well we it sounds
like we're going to explore the window
idea as a there several people would
seem like they're interested in it but
if there's another Avenue that you'd
like to explorer that gives New
Hampshire residents some sort of break
that doesn't have to be a window doesn't
have to be a a a price break but maybe
there's something else you can think
of um I think we're willing to listen I
don't know if you have anything I'm
sorry to put on the
spot
um so if I could just respond um with
the fishing game um they're law
enforcement agency so they have access
to certain databases that we don't have
state parks but that doesn't mean that
we couldn't coordinate I'm just I wanted
to throw that out there um in terms of
um do I have any ideas you know I think
at the end of the day uh I working
collaboratively is certainly the way to
go and and not only with um you know
other members of the state parks team as
well because there are there are a lot
of different ideas from all different
aspects of our operation um the the the
window uh we we would have to we' have
to talk about um how that is implemented
and where it is implemented however I I
certainly think it's possible and I'm
sure that there are some other ideas
there's also been a lot of research uh
that's been active from our staff you
know given this legislation of looking
at other state park systems and other
entities throughout the country to see
what they're doing so I think uh if if
there was a collaborative approach where
we could share some of that information
and and and maybe have a a sort of back
and forth I I think that would be
nice representative wolf did you have a
I saw you
reaching no I think he uh answered Mr
Darby's comment fishing game you do have
to show a proof of residency when you
get okay is there any other questions or
comments thank you very
much I assume you
finished you tell me I mean you were up
there well you were just came up for
question that's and I appreciate
it thank you so uh
any other comments uh by members of the
uh of the
committee this just a just a show of
hands before we exact in 10 minutes uh I
would uh let's see who would the vote
not to not recommend for future
legislation okay and for
uh and I will I will vote in the
negative on that simply because I want
to make certain that we get in into the
uh uh the what will be written on this
that this is the issue of uh non of the
diff the disparity between the treatment
of uh of our our
residents by New Hampshire and and uh
the residents of other states their
treatment by their government ex does ex
does is an issue that should be at least
discussed it sounds like it is going to
be
but just want to get it on the record so
I'll vote
now with
that I'll
uh recess or actually will adjourn the
uh the work session and at 11:30 we
will exact thank you for your time thank
you we got a
break how are you
feeling
e
e e
all right convene the executive session
on on the house
bill
1229 and chair recognizes represent
resentative R thank you Mr chair I um
move that we not
recommend um hb1 1229 for further
consideration by the legislative
body I'll second second by uh
presentative
har you wish to speak to your motion yes
Mr chair as discussed during the work
session um I believe there are other
avenues um potentially non-
legislatively to ensure that homeowners
within the shoreline protection Zone
adhere to the Shoreline water quality
protection act um I also believe that um
there are other ways also to expand that
notification to include non new buyers
like people with existing property so
that they can be alerted what
requirements are expected of them AB
buding public
way representative harb you wish to
speak to your sec to your second I
believe representative R covered thank
you is there anyone who wishes to speak
on the
motion seeing none look Qui please call
the
rooll thank you Mr chair on the motion
of not recommend um representative harb
yes representative ghoul
yes representative Horan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healey was not here
because he is resigned that's right um
representative
wolf
yes um rep representative migu is not
here representative Donnelly
yes representative Dunn is not here uh
representative
Vil yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly is not
here uh representative
Simpson yes okay it's okay
representative
Baldwin yes representative Darby
yes H is not here representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Ryan yes and the
chair yes as 15 to zero motion
passes 15 to zero okay uh there there is
no such thing as
a you there there's no consent calendar
these are these are reports
so uh I was asked you submit it through
the uh
ranking
member okay moving
on chair recognizes representative
Darby on House
Bill
1483 thank you Mr chair I'd like to make
a motion to uh recommend legislation for
House Bill
1483 is there is there a
second representative rung
second you wish to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair very briefly I um
stated most of what I wanted to say
during the work session but I think this
is uh an important bill to um some
communities that are experiencing
um water challenges and um with some
revisions um to make sure that it
doesn't
disincentivize um uh building affordable
housing and um uh and having
well-defined terms I think this a a
well-crafted piece of legislation could
come out of
us to speak to your second yes thank you
Mr chair um as mentioned in the work
session this legislation's already been
refiled the LSR is already at OS so I
think that we need to support it and
have a vetting of it when it comes
before a committee
again we uh is there anyone else who
wishes to speak to the motion
representative
wolf if the legislation has already been
filed what is the purpose of moving this
forward you're going to have two
competing bills aren't you this is not a
bill okay yeah
sure actually we don't know what's in
the other
Bill okay that's first of all and but
also it's been the tradition that we do
exactly what we're doing and it's really
what we're what we are doing is just
writing a note to
ourselves so
repes
representative thank you Mr chair I do
think it's a representative w a matter
of decorum so looking forward to the
hearings in January and February on that
next bill we don't want to look back and
have part of the hard work be that the
committee didn't think we should pursue
further legislation and that's going to
come out in chronological order so right
now we're voting
and then the legislation will come out
in December and that's the other way
around so that's why we're going to
recommend or not recommend depending on
the
motion is it representative run for a
second time yeah um just to address your
question representative
wolf interm study the outcome doesn't
really dictate any action on the
legislation we could vote to not
recommend a bill and it could still get
filed we could vote to recommend and it
doesn't get filed so it's pretty much
what the chair said it's a kind of a
note to ourselves just kind of dotting
the eyes and crossing the tees but our
vote our decision doesn't have any
actionable
outcome anyone else represent harb thank
you um even though it's a note to
ourselves I'm going to make my myself a
note that I'm not in favor of this
legislation so I'm going to vote against
the motion thank
you yeah
just yes thank you um I'm voting against
it I do know that engineering studies
are
permitted um already planning boards can
uh request an engineering study to be
paid for by the applicant H and U
hydrological studies includ flow rate is
part of that I remember uh some
subdivisions that came forward in Tilton
um so also impact fees is part of the uh
subdivision planning process already so
I think it's already covered so I'm not
uh recommending it
thanks and I will I will be voting
against it because I think the authority
is already there in uh to allow this to
be to be done
and I think this is opening up a can of
worms that uh we may find that is it
causes more difficulty uh in the future
than than we have
now would anyone else wish to speak on
the motion if not clerk please call a
role it's representative herb
no representative gold
representative Horgan no CL votes no
repesentative wolf
no representative m is not here
representative Donnelly
no representative Vale
yes representative rang yes
representative Simpson
yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative lontine
yes representative lit yes
representative Ryan yes and the
chair no that is 8 to seven motion
passes okay
moving on to Senate Bill
345 representative
Vil I make a motion to not recommend
Senate Bill
345 there a second second second by
representative wolf
anyone uh speak on your on your motion
um yes thank you Mr chair um as we heard
in testimony the fees are being reviewed
and there's quite a bit of capital
Improvement going on at the same time um
wage increases and as we heard today um
there's quite a bit of confusion about
um what exactly we would be looking at
um so for that reason I will be voting
to not recommend State Park Feast to be
changed for State
residents wolf for a sec
on I believe that we ought to be leaving
it in the hands of the
um parks department rather than dict
ating from on high what the fees should
be they know what their costs are and
they know how to best manage paying for
those
cause thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion seeing no one C please call the
rooll yes Mr chair uh on a motion of not
recommend representative harb yes
representative gold representative organ
yes cler votes yes representative wolf
yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Vale yes representative
Rong yes representative
Kelly is not here um representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
lontine yes representative lit yes
representative Brian yes and the chair
that is 14 to one motion
passes Mr chair yes sir uh before you
wind up concluding this executive
session I'd like to take a moment and
thank you for all your years of service
on this Committee in the house and your
leadership for all of us especially
myself as your Vice chair and all the
things you've taught me and your work on
the spa committee and other commit so I
I would ask my fellow reps if you would
second my recommendation if we could all
stand and give the chair a round of
applause can't you make me
cry all right I have to give back I have
to give back my R in r in right
in thank you words maybe they'll need
about thank you all I mean
it's it has been a tough it it's been a
tough tough year you know but I but I
think we all went through it and I think
we went through it great I
think especially thank the vice chair
and the ranking member and all of the
other rank other members that you know
you made it easy oh more or
less I still got I still got a few names
out but no I I you know it's it is one
it is you know the uh end theer for me
but I'll be back don't worry I I'll get
i'll get teed off about something and
I'll
be I'm sorry but I'm coming back a third
time I've already done this once
so this is my second time saying goodbye
so uh you know who knows who knows it
may just uh I maybe I may come back as
as the
opposition thank you all you it's been a
pleasure it really
is why did I thought not to come oh I
know why I didn't come back but had
nothing to do with
here e